il y a les récits au niveau de la rue de
l'univers Marvel il y a le
niveau cosmique auquel Thor et les gardiens The
Avengers nous ont emmenés mais il y a un
côté surnaturel très important Doctor
Strange est notre point d'entrée parfait
dans le fait que Benedict
Cumberbatch a  accepté de faire ce rôle
est énorme pour nous sa transformation en
étrange est vraiment extraordinaire il
affiche juste automatiquement une intelligence si féroce
qu'il semble basculer dans
ce personnage très facilement gentiment
c'est étrange, je suppose
qu'aucun jeu de mots n'a voulu qu'il ait volé sous
le radar jusqu'à maintenant  dans l'univers
cinématographique Marvel parce qu'il est
très présent dans les bandes dessinées, je pense que ce que
nous avons vu se produire dans l'
univers Marvel est cette coterie
de super-héros en constante expansion et je pense que nous sommes maintenant
au stade où cet univers même à l'
intérieur  notre monde est sur le point d'
exploser dans d'autres dimensions et je
pense que l'étrange est un pont très naturel
entre ce que nous savons de
r perceptible  réalité et quelque chose bien au-delà de ces
univers parallèles et des voyages dans le temps et de la
déconstruction et de la reconstruction Je
pense que c'est vraiment excitant et
invitant soeur toujours prête à faire
ce tour ce n'est pas notre devoir de défendre
notre monde pour ceux qui se l'
approprient vous dr.  étrange tu penses que tu sais comment le
monde fonctionne et si je te disais que la
réalité que tu sais est l'une des nombreuses
cela n'a aucun sens
tout n'est pas
nécessaire [Musique] pour les arts mystiques nous exploitons l'énergie
et façonnons la réalité
super  distances en un instant
[Musique]
donc je vais d'ici à là comment êtes-vous
devenu médecin en étudiant la pratique
hier
il y a une force pour lui mais est-il
prêt
donc quels chemins vous parcourez sur
des hommes étranges plus forts que vous avez
éclaté
j'ai la mort
quand  la douleur
qui est morte en protégeant ce monde
ne peut pas faire ça il n'y a pas d'autre moyen
j'ai passé tant d'années
à
te chercher à temps plein
mais c'est quoi mon mantra c'est le
mot de passe Wi-Fi nous ne sommes pas des sauvages
Oh
[Musique]